c'est l'image de la Commission nationale
électorale ce matin un siège vide et
toujours aucun résultat officiel 48 he
après l'élection présidentielle
ivoirienne versh les choses bougent
enfin les journalistes sont brutalement
pouss à l'écart et les commissa indépend
molest à leur
tour un groupe de militair des command
interpeller le président de la
commission hon gu celui même chargé de
proclamer les résultats un peu plus tô
les autres membres de la Commission et
les observateurs internationaux de
l'Union européenne s'y opposent il sera
finalement conduit de force vers une
destination inconnu au même moment un
communiqué élu au ministère de
l'Intérieur Robert gu
819495 soit
52,72 % en clair le généralay le chef de
l'agente se proclame vqueur de
l'élection
présidentielle Front populaire ivoirien
de Laurent bagbaau qui depuis 48 he
publie les résultats de procèsverbaux le
donnant largement vainqueur Laurent
bagbaau
répuque je demande que dans toutes les
villes de Côte d'Ivoire et dans tous les
quartiers les patriotes ivoiriens
prennent la
rue jusqu'à ce que le droit soit reconnu
et jusqu'à ce que G recul dès à présent
c'est moi le chef de l'État de Côte
d'Ivoire
aussitôt des masses de manifestants se
déploient dans une ville déjà cadriée
par les forces de
l'ordre partout dans la ville on est
riche des barrages ce soir la situation
à Abidjan est insurrectionnelle les
batailles de chiffr ont laissé place un
face àface à risque entre les civils et
certains
militaires